y destino
que cada día para la educación artística
ustedes lo pueden con nicolás mamarias
haciendo los 200 con palitos de paletas
también hacer creaciones con papel o
sino también jugar con descanso la
brillantina que las mamás hagan con
tiempo sin las barridas de los pisos
[Música]
aunque tengas las raíces
las
[Música]
delante
debes de ashton
estaba por ejemplo me la regalaron en
una tienda
recolecté también las semillitas las
manos
[Música]
y también los de las tapas de botellas
plásticas es decir es totalmente
reciclado
[Música]
precisamente en la miniatura que se
puede realizar acá se puede realizar
desde tigres se puede ver con sombras
chinas se puede realizar también hasta
multimedia no se puede
[Música]
esto está más llegando a más y llega la
oración en el año de 1989 y se vieron
por todas una américa hasta llegar al
ecuador
[Música]
se realiza en chile que se llama en
donde artistas de toda latinoamérica
niños
esta cara llegaron a mi vida en
un re profesional bastante grande yo no
tenía ni idea hasta que aprendí
y el hombre porque eran artes plásticas
eran antes mis manos yo puedo intentarlo
solamente me indica
y qué
es decir con unos niños de primaria
idealmente una cuesta
[Música]
de sensibilidad se podría descartar en
los niños
[Música]
y
los niños empezaron a enviar sus
historias en todo este tema pero un tema
muy especial los niños no crearon
historias de fantasía
a los niños les mostraron realidades que
estaban viviendo porque yo esperaba que
fueran historial de dragones de o
princesas de los sueños grandes
[Música]
una cosa fue la planta de la casa morada
una casa espectacular
era una casa completamente
desafortunadamente en una historia en
donde los padres de esta ocasión de
edición
incluso me lanza más
con los cuchillos todo lo que importa
durante estas pérdidas mentales
[Música]
y es que era una niña sana bonita se
había metido un alud de tierra en el
sitio donde vivía había tenían órdenes
acá
finamente
no tiene nada
[Música]
sin pinturas
también has escondido
[Música]
se transforma
y es donde comienzan a nacer es de menos
de sensibilidad y comienza también el
tema
recuerdo mucho también
queda
[Música]
se me dio mi mano porque obviamente
abrazando
[Música]
necesito por favor que me repita
promociones
aunque resulta que también están en esta
familia
[Música]
y no me lo quita porque encontraron en
la casa que sus hermanos mayores vendían
estupefacientes
[Música]
y obviamente se llevaron todos los niños
y las niñas
pero camino pero de que le manda salud
es inicio que sí por favor le recuerda y
medición y son los que se hacen
[Música]
primero porque el mío reportó que algo
significativo le llevarán a lo que hizo
los partidos obviamente triste porque
ningún día colombia debería estar
viviendo situaciones como esos
yo quiero hacer un llamado a los padres
de familia
a esas personas que son sus primeros
profesionalizados
a los niños y no para tener impedimento
pero también que se pueden arriesgar a
utilizar cualquier red artístico que nos
permitan comunicarnos con ellos y
volvernos a reconocer como nuestros
hijos con nuestros sobrinos todos
nuestros niños
señores porque si puedes pensar de una
humanidad
artística por la ciencia vivida en temas
de tipo pero sobre todo la comunicación
en función de mis veces muchísimas
gracias
[Aplausos]